so I was going to come in today and tell
you that a Democrat has a chance to
defeat a Republican in the state of
Montana but if I told you that it
wouldn't be accurate because it's not
that a Democrat has a chance to defeat a
Republican in Montana the truth is that
a Democrat is leading by seven against a
Republican in Montana this is a really
really big deal we'll talk about Montana
then we'll apply it a little bit broadly
in 2016
Donald Trump won Montana 56 to 36 over
Hillary Clinton 20-point win in that
state in 2014
Republican Steve Daines won his Senate
race over Amanda Curtis also by a big
margin by 1858 to 40 but incumbent
Republican Senator Steve Daines
who won in 2014 is currently down 7 -
Steve Bullock in the very red state of
Montana Steve Bullock is the current
governor of Montana according to the new
Montana State University poll released
yesterday he is ahead by seven against
the incumbent Republican senator now if
the name Steve Bullock sounds familiar
it should not just because he's the
current governor but he also was not not
particularly successful but he was in
the 2020 Democratic primary race for a
little while and even was in at least
one debate I don't remember now exactly
how many debates but he was in at least
one debate I think we've been talking
about the Senate balance in 2020 and
Democrats need to have a net gain of
three seats plus the presidency or a net
gain of four seats if Trump gets
reelected to take control of the Senate
now why what does that mean why does
that matter whether Trump wins or loses
if you have a Senate that's 50/50 the
tiebreaker is the vice president of
course if the tiebreaker is Mike Pence
that doesn't go Democrats way so if
Trump were to get reelected Democrats
would need to get to 51 seats if Biden
wins they only need to get to 50 so
we're assuming and I believe that it's a
fair assumption that Democrats are going
to lose
the Doug Jones scene in Alabama that's
the special election seat it used to be
Jeff session Senate seat jeff sessions
was made donald trump's beleaguered
attorney general so that seat was up for
special election doug jones won against
the republican nominee who was serial
accused a sex assault or roy more now
jeff sessions is trying to win his old
seat back and he's winning very very
handily in the polling in alabama so
there's every indication democrats are
gonna lose that seat in alabama
so to net three you've got to find four
wins to net four you've got to find five
wins because you're gonna lose that one
seat so what are we looking at arizona
we've talked about arizona before mark
kelly against the incumbent republican
martha mcsalley she is in the seat
previously held by john mccain the late
john mccain she's not won in the
election she was appointed their main
Sarah Gideon is doing well against
longtime incumbent senator Susan Collins
a Republican who's often disappointed
with Trump but eventually sides with him
in Colorado Cory Gardner is not doing
particularly well in North Carolina Thom
Tillis could lose which would be great
but now with the addition of Montana
this adds a new element now a few
caveats on the seven-point lead that
Steve Bullock has in Montana number one
it's 46 to 39 so it's a seven-point lead
but 46 plus 39 is only 85 that leaves 15
up in the air and sometimes that breaks
for the incumbent so that's one caveat
um one of the reasons that Bullock is
doing well in Montana is that as the
current governor as I told you he's done
really well with coronavirus he has a
seventy percent approval on his handling
of coronavirus only a forty eight
percent approval for the incumbent
Senator Steve Daines
in terms of his handling of coronavirus
of course governors and Senators have
different roles in the context of
coronavirus 2020 could quickly become
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell's
worst nightmare if some of these races
go the Democrats way but it's up to us
to
it's so we need to get out and vote and
not assume any single race in any state
now I have other outrageous news for
Montana as well there is a hypothetical
presidential polling being done I guess
at this point it's not really
hypothetical in the sense that Joe
Biden's the only candidate left Trump is
only ahead by five in the presidential
polling against Joe Biden in Montana
remember in 2016 Trump beat Hillary by
20 in Montana now admittedly libertarian
Gary Johnson got five points in Montana
in 2016 so maybe that these numbers need
to be adjusted for that but this is a
big swing call it a 10-point swing call
it a 15-point swing if indeed Donald
Trump only wins Montana by five it would
be a very bad November for Donald Trump
does it pass the sniff test that Trump
is only up five in Montana I don't know
I honestly don't know these are early
numbers anyway we shouldn't be assuming
anything there's much to work for but
the Senate which a year ago I would look
two years ago I was saying Democrats
don't really have a chance in November
of 2020 for the Senate of one year ago I
was saying it's possible but it's a big
uphill battle six months ago I was
saying it's possible now this is a real
possibility I don't I don't think it's
likely I think I still think if I had to
bet I would say you got to give me odds
to bet on Democrats in taking the Senate
but there is now a very clear path and
it is not a wholly unrealistic path
Democrats would need a couple of these
races to go against the incumbent in the
end that can be tough but a lot of good
races to get involved in and really
great numbers out of Montana we'll keep
following it